Danny Green he as part of this trade he
had to be waved in order to make room
and one thing I want to say about Danny
Green sources inform me that Danny Green
actually restructured his contract
before the start of the Season he took
less money to help the team out with tax
purposes and now he's he's being waved
and so that's a tough situation for him
his his situation was that if he was on
a roster if he was on a Sixers roster
open at night he would get 500,000 well
he restructured it where he would get
200,000 um to help out with with tax
purposes and now he's waved so this is
just the business of the NBA business of
the league and you know the Sixers felt
like he had a really strong Camp one of
the strongest strong camps um on the
team and there's a possibility he could
be brought back um down the road but you
know it's an unfortunate situation for
guys like him